immaginate un ragazzino impaurito timido
e anche immaturo che a 16 anni decide
perché si fa influenzare anche degli
amici che hanno la possibilità di
prendersi il motorino La vespa andare in
discoteca e io non potevo a livello
economico Quindi decido di andare sul
mondo di lavoro
primo lavoro
decido di trovo questo lavoro di fare il
saldatore quindi a 16 anni entro su
questa fabbrica dove che mi danno in
mano una pistola per saldare container
mi dicono devi fare così e Siediti con
il grembiule col kurame e inizio a fare
il saldatore
problema è che era anche l'inverno
quello stragelido Addirittura mi ricordo
che avevo il pigiama sotto da quanto
freddo che c'era quell'inverno e a un
certo punto dopo mezz'ora che lavoro non
riesco dal freddo che c'è Non riesco a
piegare il dito quindi vado in centro
via fabbrica in centro la fabbrica c'era
una bidone con dentro della legna accesa
e tolgo il guanto ti scaldi la mano
rimetti il guanto ritorna a fare il
saldatore e questo per tre quattro volte
al giorno il tempo che man mano che le
mani si mollavano quindi diciamo non
inizio dei migliori vado a militare
Alpino orgoglioso di essere Alpino tra
poco cioè la grande Donata
e
torno a fine della leva Faccio richiesta
su una grande multinazionale della
dell'abbigliamento Mi assumono come
magazziniere
la inizio conosco il mio attuale socio e
sia che lui ci sentivamo stretti in
fabbrica volevamo fare un qualcosa di
diverso quindi a tempo perso abbiamo
iniziato a fare i venditori di Porta a
porta quindi coperte lana Merino pentole
un po' di tutto A un certo punto decido
di licenziarmi rilevo un Quindi grande
salto posto fisso
pensate nel 90 avere un posto fisso era
il massimo quindi decidere di fare
questo salto nel vuoto decido di levare
un laboratorio fallito con sette persone
da 7 mi impegno al massimo inizio alle
6:30 al mattino in non mi vergogno a
dire che ho imparato a Cucire a macchina
quindi taglia e cuci due aghi lo so fare
di tutto perché per insegnare il lavoro
alle mie ragazze volevo collaborare con
loro per insieme portare avanti questo
quindi 7 persone 10 15 20 50 80
è successo contento del risultato nel
frattempo mi sento sempre col mio ex
collega ma è nata una grande amicizia
lui si era licenziato per andare a fare
il venditore di mobili litiga col suo
titolare da oggi e domani quindi si
trova in mezzo alla strada e decide di
partire con l'azienda viene da me mi
chiedeva Io sono forte commercialmente
però a livello di controllo gestione di
Finanza non ne capisco nulla Va bene
accetto e quindi 7 in mattina
laboratorio fino alle 2 dalle dalle
due partivo facevo 30 km in un edificio
e da là Quindi doppio lavoro fino ai 7
gradi di sera
e nel questo successo nel 95 ottobre al
95 partiamo con questa azienda ma senza
soldi quindi si parla a 20 milioni di
lire pari 10 milioni di lire adesso puoi
partire con questo e e e difatti
troviamo uno stabile e un capannone
all'interno di una zona industriale
Quindi tutto tranne che commerciale ma
questo a volte si fa delle scelte errate
in questo caso inconsapevoli ma anche
non avendo potenzialità economica di
fare questo ma può essere dopo il motivo
che ti fa
mettere in moto per dire come fai a
portare delle persone a visitare il tuo
showroom e quindi
telemarketing centri commerciali un po'
di tutto per far sì che di di far
arrivare i clienti quindi questo è stato
stimolo per creare vari canali per
portare i clienti dell'azienda questa
era il lontano 95 dove
che partendo
dove che si
Come posso spiegarlo
dove fin dall'inizio abbiamo messo per
noi era il nostro sogno e quindi abbiamo
messo passione amore per tutto quello
che è il lavoro e abbiamo sempre creduto
molto in tutte quelle che sono le
risorse quindi formazione possibilità di
crescita e
di avere di parametri di misurazioni in
modo che ci fosse un avanzamento di
carriera giustificata
come dicevo famiglia Povera Marica
Povera perché
ha 11 anni mi è mancato il papà
e quindi
ma mamma in pensione con la minima e per
questo ovviamente mi ricordo che andavo
alla sera al bar o potevo bere un caffè
una birra perché entrambi non potevo
permettermelo però ricca perché non ho
mai sentito la mancanza di niente
rispetto amore protezione
e sono valori che mi sono di portata
avanti col tempo e ho cercato anche
ovviamente di trasmetterli nella mia
azienda
i valori che ho cercato anche
trasmettere la mia azienda è crescita
carriera Quindi la possibilità a tutti
quanti di avanzare
i miei centri siamo circa in 22/23
posizioni in Italia Chi sono i direttori
i direttori sono persone che sono hanno
iniziato a fare il consulente il
promoter che poi diventa responsabile
chiediamo se è disposto a trasferirti a
Roma per aprire la sede di Roma sì e
quindi lo integriamo all'interno
dell'azienda gli diamo anche una quota
societaria un 20% dell'azienda e quindi
se io vado a Roma per me è la sede
chiedo permesso perché per me la sede è
di Matteo che porta avanti le cose
questo è bello perché dopo questo crea
anche una sana competizione quindi tra
tutti i direttori delle sedi fanno una
sana competizione con Premium
comunicazione ascolto continua costante
miglioramento Questo è un fondamento che
mi ha portato mi ha aiutato tantissimo
andare avanti perché avendo smesso di
andare a scuola a 16 anni quando c'è
stato un momento della crescita mi sono
ritrovato che gestire 30 40 50 persone e
sentivo che non era acculturato e il
colmo era che non non avevo
quando andavo a scuola Il libro lo
vedevo come un obbligo ho voluto
cambiare il mio perché e quindi il guaio
e ho immaginato ho iniziato a leggere i
libri immaginato che l'autore del libro
fosse sopra il palco con io l'unico
spettatore e che lui mi raccontasse
tutto quanto le loro le sue strategie le
sue maniere la sua esperienza e io
assorbivo ho iniziato a leggere il libro
due libri tre libri due libri a
settimana ho iniziato a fare corsi ho
iniziato a un fatto di tutto PNL
programmazione linguistica funziona a
camminare sui carboni ardenti a Londra
con Anthony Robbins sono andato in mezzo
a una foresta in Croazia
dovevo migliorare la comunicazione
rompere la mia timidezza
sono andato in Croazia mi ricordo
eravamo in otto con questo Marco pare
che spiegava la
l'ipnosi e quindi a me serviva i
linguaggi ipnotico per la comunicazione
in azienda quindi avventure stranissime
un po' di tutto e ancora adesso che
cerco di tornare e mettermi in forma e
quindi alla mattina
metto su le cuffiette vado a camminare e
mi ascolto per un'ora e mezza il libro
tramite audible che questo mi aiuta e
continuo a buttare dentro informazioni
per poter continuare a crescere perché
serve tirar fuori creatività e
innovazione se pensi di essere arrivato
il momento che che accade a terra Quindi
sempre la ricerca di di novità per
potenziare l'azienda per migliorarla in
tutto e per tutto atteggiamento mentale
positivo è assolutamente e
organizzazione strutturata che poi vi
spiegherò l'ho creato una Vision
dell'azienda la forza di un gruppo
sempre in movimento perché essendo
sempre innovatori che troviamo sistemi
sempre nuovi per arredare i sogni del
cliente
iniziamo nel
96 senza soldi decidiamo di fare come
facciamo a portare i clienti in azienda
era il cambio 95 99 mi sembra il l'ira
euro
decidiamo di fare un volantino
Addirittura due colori per risparmiare
sul prezzo e vado
in banca mi viene ancora da ridere
arrivo in banca a Piombino Dese e con
uno due milioni di euro e sono di lire
adesso non mi ricordo neanche più e gli
dico vorrei che mi cambiassi da 10 lire
preoccupato sono andato fuori dalla
banca con tre quattro sacchi di monete
da 10 E allora per ogni volantino Ci
siamo messi tutti quanti Io ho compreso
con la pistola a caldo a pindere i dieci
lire sul volantino che così uno arrivava
a carico volantino potevi guardarlo ma
non potevi buttare via anche dieci lire
perché insomma porta un po' di
questo è ha fatto un successone che
dal weekend dopo
300-400 copie quindi
molto forte con tantissimi della cosa è
stato il momento della televisione
decide di perfetto Creiamo un altro
canale vogliamo fare gli spot e quindi
chiamiamo
una persona importante di un mio
competitor che mi dà una mano per fare
la televisione fare le zapping quindi
con la decisione locale e quindi
pianifichiamo tutto quindi i vari spot
78 televisioni eccetera mi preparo il
conto dico guardo guardo i miei Social
dico Franco Se per caso non funziona
Sappi per due tre anni avremo seri
problemi economici credimi cosa dici
Andiamo andiamo forza Facciamo questo
mega investimento e da là successone
continuiamo a avere questo pubblico che
ci venga a trovare tutti quanti quindi
ehm in quel momento abbiamo rischiato la
sua il collo ma sono quei momenti di
decisioni che sono obbligate per fare se
vuoi fare un salto in avanti o tenere i
risultati formazione personale è quella
che ho appena raccontato che trovandomi
in difficoltà così
libri Libri leggere ma non solo i libri
a leggere però i libri casa mia e in
ufficio Sono pieno di libri ma i miei
libri sono con i post-it con la pena
Sottolineata Cerco si ottengono un
concetto di di un di un personaggio lo
cerco di metterlo subito in atto per
ottenere il risultato e questo è stato
per me Per la mia azienda la nostra
azienda è stata fondamentale per
continuare a fare la crescita arriva il
vado su una situazione così su una a
Vicenza sopra il palco c'è Martin
limstrong numero uno del Brand al mondo
vado fuori da questa giornata dopo tre
ore come vado a fare carico di energia
non mi ricordo Passo prendo la macchina
dal passo il Telepass e
diamo la mia responsabile marketing
l'unica persona che mi dà ancora lei in
azienda non riesco più perché e e e la
chiamo dico Alessandra adesso ho visto
questo personaggio console non voglio
più Il Tondo con scritto payoff è
finalmente casa
Voglio un cambio Voglio il cuore al
posto del tondo e passione amore e
voglio che tutti quelli che lavorano
all'interno della nostra azienda lo
fanno con passione amore per il rispetto
dei propri collabora dei propri colleghi
collaboratori per rispetto dei clienti
ma cosa vuol dire Ottavia vuol dire che
domani
devo cambiare il cartelline devo
cambiare il
le Insigne l'insegna sulle aziende eh
dico sì le posso dire qualcosa
Dimmi Alessandra fa Spero che non vada
più fare questi corsi
quindi inumazioni i parametri di
crescita scuola formazione insomma siamo
un'azienda che siamo sempre alla ricerca
successo online in questo momento stiamo
Ottenendo
75.000 lead mese
vado veloce perché vedo che il tempo sta
venendo
95 a 95 a oggi
non parte la slide Comunque siamo un
gruppo forte 22 persone 500 nella
collaborazione in Italia e abbiamo
superato 120 milioni l'anno scorso
Quindi felicissimi di Mega risultati e
stiamo continuando a crescere per amo
così